isn't it crazy when you find out there's
a different way a different way to get
out yeah underneath on 148th Street was
a hobby shop he sold glue and models
there was always this guy in front of
the place like twitching you know he
would go skip command
go in there buy me some glue really yeah
five months later one of my jobs when I
stayed with my godmother was to help her
take the garbage out for the buildings
and I went to the garbage cans and as
I'm pulling up this sticky Charlie
there's Charlie's sitting there with a
bag just going
and he saw him and I'm like Charlie what
the [__] you doing and he got up and
when he went to fling the [__] bag he
had glue on his hand so the bag stuck to
his hand and I'm like you [__]
you don't build no [__] models like I
believed him yeah like I I fought for
you for [__] months I'm at home
thinking you're building models and this
is what you do to me you dirty
[__]